in 2023
if you still support Donald Trump
you deserve to have every penny drained
from your bank account if you're giving
them money if that's what happens to you
or what you decide to do
Donald Trump's fans sent him a million
and a half dollars in three days after
he falsely predicted he would be
arrested on Tuesday
a fool and their money are soon parted
does that apply here
Business Insider reports Trump wasn't
arrested but he got a big fundraising
boost raising 1.5 million dollars into
three days after saying he'd be arrested
that's nearly double the daily average
he got in the weeks before and after
launching his 2024 bid
the campaign confirmed the sum to Fox
News the money was said to be raised
from Grassroots donations raising about
five hundred thousand a day is about
double what Trump was previously
averaging the Trump campaign brought in
11.8 million in the six weeks before the
announcement which averages out to about
280 000 a day
in the six weeks after Trump's
announcement he raised about 226
000 today but then he wrote they're
going to arrest me we need to protest
take the nation back Soros deep state
conspiracy and on and on and on
and then he started including videos
like the one we just looked at talking
about how he will dismantle the Deep
State he started including those videos
inside of fundraising emails and he said
we need your support donate so we can do
this if you're not doing well don't send
any money but if you can if you can
afford it please send me some money
it is incredible is it pejorative to say
that you would have to be moronic to
fall for this at this point in time now
you might be saying
what on Earth motivates an individual
to give money to a billionaire because
they claim they're about to be arrested
and argue that they are going to
dismantle the so-called deep State what
on Earth would motivate someone to give
that individual money
and you have to remember that this is a
cult
it is a cult where some in the cult
believe that Donald Trump was sent by
God to save the United States of America
from a cabal of democratic pedophiles
if you believe that
it's not a very far stretch to say
you're going to send a little bit of
money
and that is a big part of understanding
what is going on here and like I said at
this point if you are still a trump
supporter in 2023
it's it's really buy or beware and the
downside of course is I don't want to
see people heard and for a lot of these
folks donating money it's probably their
Social Security money that's going to
Trump uh based on the average uh you
know the disproportionately advanced age
of trump supporters
um and the financial reality of many of
these folks the other aspect to this of
course is that there's a long history I
mean go back to the tea party you can go
back longer but at least in the modern
era go back to the tea party and you
will remember people who will never
benefit from lowering taxes on the rich
voting in favor of candidates who want
to lower taxes on the rich why doesn't
make sense it's the same thing with
Trump supporting a guy who isn't going
to do anything that's going to help you
Jonathan height has really done a lot of
very good Research into this it is not
about voting for what I think is best
for me it's about voting for what I have
been convinced or tricked into believing
this is now my editorializing of it what
I have if if I can be tricked into
believing that what's based best for my
entire group
is to support someone like Trump or a
candidate that will lower taxes on the
ridge I will vote that way
for group cohesion even if most of the
members of that group won't actually
benefit for the thing that they are
voting in favor of you have to
understand that to understand why
someone at this point would say I'll
donate to Trump and I'll vote for Trump
even though he's supposedly a
billionaire and his policies won't
actually do anything for me read
Jonathan Heights work on that and it'll
be very Illuminating
Trump capitalizing on the arrest claim
will he pay his lawyers I don't know
will he actually get arrested next week
I don't know I'm waiting to see just as
much as you are